i was bony [ __ ] i was still that
that skinny kid that was made fun of for
the most part for my style people did
not like my style at all is your style
considered different well it was more
and at that time it was more focused on
tricks and it wasn't about it wasn't
about
flow and speed and power and aerials it
was more like i was doing these little
spins and stuff with my skateboard like
i was twirling a baton so they they said
i was doing circus tricks
but the fact that i had validation from
stacy peralta went a long way
so once i got on the bones brigade and
started to do well in different events
then that that narrative changed well
you changed the style right or what
people looked for in the whole sport um
there was a technique that i developed
that that i was made fun of originally
that now is the standard way that people
do aerials so but when you were young
and they were making fun of this style
did you
i'm fascinated that a young kid but it
sucked but i would think that i would be
as a young person going you know what
they're making fun of me i'm going to
try to do it the way they're doing it
you didn't change i didn't have the
strength to do that i was so skinny that
that i was doing it out of desperation
because i was doing this technique where
when when the like the dog town crew and
the the people of the late 70s when they
would do aerials out of pools they would
reach down and grab their board before
they got to the top right and then just
kind of muscle it into the air and it
was just more like a hop
and what i developed is is doing an
ollie
near the top and then launching myself
into the air and then grabbing my board
at the apex and the reason i did that is
because i didn't have the strength to
muscle myself into the air so i had to
launch
and that became the way to do it because
you could get way more higher that way
you don't you don't kill your speed by
reaching down for your board before you
leave the pool and this is also the
predecessor to do you snowboard yeah
and and skateboard would be the
predecessor there wasn't snowboarding at
the time no so and all those tricks and
all those the ollies and all that is the
same terminology that they're using in
uh yeah snowboarding has kind of taken
on a life of its own because now it's a
lot of gymnastics type of moves and
they're not just flips and things and
you don't do that in skateboarding um we
do a bit of that but it but it's just
different it's just a different it's a
different plane and and you're attached
to the board so the ollie is sort of
is redundant and and
and i find this fascinating that you
started doing this
as a kid for transportation you created
a style and now this style is uh what is
looked upon as professionally i mean i
watched it in the olympics for the first
time right yeah yeah
i mean you're still a young guy i mean
in your life from 10 years old to 53
you're watching something that you did
your brother takes you to a park i go oh
that's kind of cool and because you did
it because i believe that you are a
leader of this sport not only are you
well known don't no thank you you i had
a skateboard when i was a little kid but
nothing i did was going to lead to
changing the world i'm older than you
i'm a decade older than you and and i
had it i had a
wooden
shitty wooden flat i think i had a two
by four with some wheels from uh from
roller skates yeah yeah that's that's
right it was the same way that's what i
had them and that's how i used to go to
my friend's house when i didn't want to
take my bike
but you tried this thing out and now the
world is watching it on look who's here
do you know this guy oh
hey do you know do you know theo vaughn
i do i just got to i had
[Laughter]
before you measure this why don't you
measure
[Laughter]
are you buying carpet for me
[Laughter]
i'm going to document this now like this
this whole thing has just gone south so
we're talking about that
that's what happens
do you skateboard no i you know what i
used to rollerskate a little but that's
not even where do you want this at the
wall
wait what's written are you renovating
this place
theo not only does comedy but theo does
i
i'm so confused so am i i have no idea
this is not a plan but welcome to the
sorry i do some light flooring no i was
just trying to see if we do our thing
here what it's going to be like
what you keep moving it though dad i
don't know i was holding did you get the
measurement you needed
[Laughter]
all right
good luck with that project oh
appreciate it no worries man i'm just
putting a small
quarter ramp here oh double quarter a
double quarter amp wouldn't that be a
half ramp well
you know what i did i built a half pipe
in my garage yeah for alex right really
yeah i did awesome my son
for my son supportive well the problem
was that they uh the garage
is so he would go up and then smash his
face into the ceiling
it wasn't a good idea i there was no
engineering involved
you thought that counts no but let's
finish this uh i have a question but
wait wait i have a question what the
[ __ ] just happened
yeah
i have a lot of questions at this point
go ahead
[Music]
bye